[Música]
la cadena de noticias británica bbc
reintegró esta semana a su presentador
mejor pagado y quien también es ex
capitán de fútbol de Inglaterra se trata
de Gary liniquer quien había sido
suspendido por criticar la política
Estatal de inmigración que propone
Richie sunak y esto que la está
defendiendo en el parlamento la salida
del presentador produjo un boicot por
parte de otros periodistas y una
reacción negativa del público por lo que
este sábado regresa para el programa
insignia de la Premier League llamado
match of the day o partido del día que
ha presentado limiquer desde 1999 Pero
esto no se va a quedar seguramente sin
consecuencias pues aún bbc tendrá que
lidiar con las críticas que ha tenido la
conversación sobre este tema es con
Ezequiel Fernández murs periodista
deportivo argentino y autor de dígame
Ringo y juego luego existo antes de
darle la bienvenida también le quiero
dar la bienvenida a Juan pupiales
nuestro periodista deportivo que nos
acompaña en estudio Ahora sí hablemos
porque el fin de semana pasado la bbc
pasó momentos vergonzosos al tener que
Cancelar prácticamente todos los
programas de Gary liniquare y luego
presentadores expertos periodistas
también deportivos de la bbc se sumaron
a esto y dejaron de presentar yo le
quiero preguntar Cómo afecta este
episodio a todo el periodismo sobre todo
en Reino Unido
buenas a todos primero María Clara Juan
y el resto de la audiencia bueno a ver
lo que el debate central el debate
central son los la situación de los
refugiados y los inmigrantes en el Reino
Unido no ese es el debate central como
el propio linaker se encargó de aclarar
una vez rehabilitado por la cadena
pública luego para los periodistas para
nosotros el debate central pasa a ser
nuestra Libertad en las redes a mí
personalmente no me gusta mucho las
redes pero una vez que estamos allí en
el debate si nos debemos a la
corporación en la que trabajamos o si
nuestra libertad como periodista para
hablar es plena representamos a esa
corporación en la que trabajamos o
representamos nuestra opinión Juan libre
somos cuando los medios justamente lo
que principalmente proclaman es la
libertad de prensa
Ezequiel a raíz de ese caso de línea con
el saludo para usted la bbc se propone
cambiar su política de redes sociales
una política que dice que todos sus
empleados a través de sus redes sociales
deben defender deben promover la
imparcialidad de la bbc La pregunta es
fue ese comentario de Liner un
comentario parcializado Se puede decir
sí claramente yo personalmente no no
creo mucho en el término objetividad
somos sujetos que opinamos sobre sujetos
y sobre hechos provocados por por
sujetos
no somos objetos las piedras son objetos
no nuestra opinión nuestros prejuicios
nuestra formación lo que sí creo Es en
la honestidad periodística línea que
siempre ha tenido un pronunciamiento que
si podría decir en términos muy simples
Si se quiere entrecomillados
progresistas
y la cadena pública ha permitido la bbc
ha permitido que otro tipo de
periodistas y y sobre todo expresiones
un poco más conservadoras y alineadas
con los gobiernos conservadores que ha
tenido el Reino Unido en los últimos
años pudieron expresarse nunca había
habido problemas y sí lo subo con
linares
no solo piensa de modo opuesto al
gobierno sino que además es un nombre
muy famoso es rostro público muy popular
porque el fútbol es eso es una pasión
popular y línea que sabemos se
desenvuelve de modo muy hábil y muy
liviano con sus opiniones él se como
dice soy periodista deportivo no estoy
que comprometiendo tanto a la cadena
Porque soy un periodista deportivo no
voy a actuar en política pero en sus
redes públicas Sí él se pronunció en
contra del brexit y ahora se pronunció
de modo muy fuerte en contra de la
política sobre inmigrantes y sobre todo
él utilizó una comparación con el
lenguaje de la Alemania de los años 30
del nazismo claro Esto fue lo que
provocó la explosión de estos días y tal
como usted lo mencionó uno de los
grandes argumentos del ineker y de
quienes lo respaldan es que no es el
primer caso de una opinión personal de
un periodista británico o un periodista
puntualmente de la bbc no sé si usted
conozca que otros casos ha habido antes
y sobre todo Quiero conocer su postura
frente a si los periodistas en sus redes
personales deben asumir o no la misma
postura editorial del medio de
comunicación
a ver los otros periodistas que se
pronunciaron Sí Uno de ellos tiene el
lord Sugar es uno de los comentaristas
más porque recordemos que Gary naker no
es un personal de staff de la bbc en
términos de otros periodistas que tienen
un vínculo permanente diario y cotidiano
línea que eres un presentador de uno de
los programas más populares de la bbc
como es el del fútbol el match of the
day como decías María Clara
y la la la la otra situación a ver yo
creo que personalmente yo dije que a mí
no me gustan las redes yo creo que las
redes son más para que se exprese gente
que no tiene donde expresarse los
periodistas sí tenemos donde expresarnos
a mí me parecía inicialmente interesante
el debate de más democrático de las
redes porque permitía que otras voces se
expresaran así Si así se expresan
también las voces de nosotros los mismos
periodistas y medio como que seguimos
monopolizando Esa esa voz pública dicho
esto Bueno una vez que el periodista
interviene en la red y a mí me parece
que el periodista es el periodista sobre
todo cuando Gary lilinaker es un nombre
muy poderoso ese nombre tan poderoso en
términos individuales le conviene a la
bbc porque se supone que convoca
audiencia galilina bueno las
consecuencias de tener un nombre tan
poderoso es que ese nombre tan poderoso
tiene pensamiento propio un activo muy
valioso dijo textualmente la bbc en ese
comunicado cuando anunció el reingreso
del ineker a la cadena quiero
profundizar en esa figura de
Ezequiel para que la audiencia lo
entienda Cuál es el peso de yereleneger
en la audiencia británica teniendo en
cuenta que es un presentador muy
carismático y que además representa una
de las épocas más gloriosas del fútbol
inglés de finales de los 80 comienzos de
los 90 esa semifinal de Italia 90 un
goleador que añora mucha nostalgia para
la audiencia británica sobre todo para
audiencias para generaciones anteriores
claro inclusive yo desde Argentina
escribí sobre Gary lineker y este
conflicto con la bbc porque Gary Liner
Casi nos arruina a los argentinos la
fiesta de México 86 recordemos que
Argentina le ganaba aquel histórico
partido dos Cero en el Estadio Azteca a
la selección inglesa y Gary lineker fue
quien descontó en los últimos minutos y
casi anota el empate dos dos que hubiese
provocado una largue lo que finalmente
no ocurrió Argentina gana ese partido y
sabemos luego Maradona mediante
Argentina es campeona mundial es decir
No solo en Argentina el nombre de
garylinear y no solo para los ingleses
es un nombre muy poderoso y muy
convocante en el fútbol mundial tanto
que su carrera de comentarista Casi casi
diría yo que supera su notable carrera
como futbolista recordemos que fue
goleador en el Barcelona de España
también esto le dio a Karina que era una
visión muy global del mundo del fútbol y
de las comunicaciones y él es muy Abre
es un gran Comenta y sabe reírse de sí
mismo de su pasado como jugador
inclusive con lo cual ha ganado una gran
empatía con la audiencia y esto él lo
sabe aprovechar muy bien No solo es un
comentarista principal en la bbc sino
que además es un gran comentarista en
general otras cadenas lo han contratado
él tiene una productora que le genera
ahora genera un gran ingreso porque es
una fortuna de los especialistas han
estimado cerca de veintiséis millones de
libras que ha acumulado Porque además
vende muchos productos en la a través de
los medios a partir de su gran imagen
y yo le quiero hacer muy brevemente la
última pregunta y es Cuáles son las
consecuencias que enfrenta la bbc sobre
todo teniendo en cuenta que ya venía de
polémicas anteriores por ejemplo el
presidente de la cadena británica
Richard le había hecho un préstamo a
Boris Johnson antes de que se conociera
que iba a ser el Primer Ministro
británico Cuáles son las consecuencias
para la cadena
quedó un poco dañada la cadena en
realidad pues tuvo que retroceder en la
sanción inicial lo había suspendido
temporalmente tuvieron que rehabilitarlo
porque creo que no esperaran que tuviera
tanta solidaridad de sus colegas ex
jugadores y periodistas que decidieron
no transmitir el match of the day del
fin de semana pasado de 90 minutos
habituales tuvo que reducirse a 20
minutos porque no hubo voces no hubo
comentarios no hubo entrevistas de campo
a los jugadores el bochorno para la bbc
fue muy grande la bbc anunció que
revisará su política sobre redes
sociales y la galileker no tuvo que
disculparse con lo cual su imagen quedó
fortalecida una imagen fortalecida
entonces de Gary linier y una bbc
afectada Ezequiel Gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en directo a América
Hasta luego Muchas gracias Un placer y
Gracias también a ustedes Juan pupiales
por acompañarnos ustedes sigan
conectados con directo América porque es
minutos tenemos más noticias
[Música]